Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
by two kills one by two kills ya none of
which were mine Thanks Oh someone asks
battlefield 3 or modern warfare 3 John
Luke
oh is that a heavy question the
battlefield proofer for me personally
just I prefer battlefield that's kind of
my forte
have they made any of those games
backwards-compatible on this yet
actually I typically play battlefield on
the PC so ok that hasn't concerns me as
much though that's a good question you
think because it'd only be three yeah
four was four as uh it was like a launch
game nosy year after it was it was on
the ps4 and Xbox one
yeah maybe three would be backwards
compatible I don't know if they've done
that yet though whoo hard hat
whoops kick the system here okay it
looks like we're doing if you're
watching this on youtube you won't see
this for a while but uh YouTube's a bit
behind right now apologies have some
weird issues with YouTube recently in
this room I don't know why hmm
if you're wondering for on the exit vs
round X we are on the X we are on the X
what's your favorite map oh I remember
this one
I remember hard hat hard hat is a good
one it's really small um my favourite
map though jeez I'd have to look at a
list like the there was a lot of good
deal see in this one so I have to like
differentiate between all that stuff but
this is another good short one where the
middle is always super hot right like
there's a sewage system in this level
that that's where all the the flashbangs
go off and everything like that watch
you'll see here in a second
I really like the campaign of the modern
warfare series and just hearing this
guy's voices announcer guys boys just
bring me back to home yeah mana warfare
to arguably might have had the better
campaign but uh three sort of ended kind
of crap brought into it I wouldn't say
end it but cuz a modern warfare 4 is
coming back oh really I see where takes
off some here confirm it's it's like the
heaviest rumor I think it's like
everything all but confirmed at this
point like it's infinity ward's next
entries is the rumors and we'll see I
don't know I don't know from there yeah
this kind of weird thing with like black
ops is sort of the same way we're like
black ops 3 technically took place in
the same universe as like 1 and 2 but
didn't really have much of a story tie
in the way what I'm to did and you know
warfare 1 2 3 obviously like had a whole
story to them yeah so really big ending
- exactly so it's not really much of a
reason to have or also like the only
character left alive at the end of 4 is
or at the end of three was price yeah
like everyone else dies in that game
everyone everyone great ending though
great ending uh uh pay that oh my so
many rewards for just killing one guy
Oh upstairs over here actually this is a
sewer area I talked about in the middle
here we're good I think the stream on
YouTube finally caught up all right
welcome you - good good good
Pilar asking ya for playing on the X yes
we are we're not playing for cakes can't
stream in 4k I don't know if it has 4k
support that's actually a good good is a
good question check that
let's find out I'm gonna get some no I
feel like people would have mentioned
that a lot of people were like oh yeah
it's on backwards compatible but I don't
think it has some hands support it looks
good though looks really good
oh yeah this move 60 which is always
nice you know yeah that's the one thing
about Carl duty is always like that that
smooth frame rate yeah even on console
they just always pulled it off looks
great now it doesn't seem like it has
any sort of ants and Hance support on
the X or anything like that it's just go
so you'll get this experience on
whatever I xbox you're playing it on
don't I didn't check how many people are
playing but I'm kind of curious it's
always interesting going back to and I
meant overall yeah we can check in the
lobby
yeah I always find that curious how many
people are like still playing you know
when I was checking out the original
black ops a month the two ago yeah like
30,000 people playing we were like 10 to
15 playing to which I kind of figured to
would have more but I guess people are
more nostalgic for one yeah especially
towards the end like where we're ending
the life cycle of World War 2 here and
people start going back to like all
these old games especially now they're
there riah becoming more backwards
compatible here supported was up here I
thought
whoops Jephunneh III I did have fun at
e3 it's very busy but it's very good
yeah you guys were holding it down here
right yeah how's that just like it's uh
this year was much calmer because on our
team on top of like no one being here
our team priority is to like get the
trailers out for all the latest games so
like on the few on the final days of e3
it's a little slower for us because the
conference is stopped but you guys are
out there on the floor like playing all
these demos and stuff so sure totally
different around here it is although at
least for me I like direct our stage
show and stuff like that so I'm not
necessarily I don't get to really
experience e3 like I still feel like the
best way to fully experience e3 is to
just stay at home especially the press
conferences because like on our end
we're sitting there we're like breaking
out stories and videos and we really you
know you just watch it home you just get
to enjoy it right yeah you get to
actually enjoy it I did get to see the
one thing that no one else can see cyber
fun did get to see cyber that's been the
hot buzz around the office anyone who's
seen is like oh my god yes cyber fun so
one of those things where everyone's
like okay you're all talking up this
demo and I was one of the last people to
see it and I was like all right let's
see how cool it really is and then I was
like it's cool it's cool
cool this confirmed it's cool it has a
has a cool meter actually well you have
like stats cuz it's an RPG and ah what
else did you enjoy out there did you get
it well you were you were still like
back in the house for most of the time
but did you get to play any other demos
or anything any other you know that was
the only one I got to play I really want
to play Resident Evil 2 oh my god
wanting to and I and unfortunately they
were like alright John we can go see
Resident Evil it's at 3 that's also my
son of a punk demo was man of course it
shows cyberpunk but I was still a man
I both I believe Tony caught gameplay
for us and I haven't been able to watch
it cuz I just I want to go in as fresh
as possible the only thing I want to
watch is that trailer Resident Evil 2 is
like I've heard it's really good yeah oh
man it looks amazing so far yeah
someone's asked an online population
yeah do we want to hop out for a second
yeah actually I thought it did down here
somebody laughs maybe not this game B
they don't in this one mmm don't recalls
here nope just my net type okay bummer I
feel like in this game that was an
option yes I always thought they did I
mean it's still fairly populated it
seems my bad the heatmap all right I
guess find a match then yeah oh look at
that oh here we go there now she does
leave back up here there we go
in the standard platelet 18,000 total
that's pretty good that is really good
it's pretty good maybe a little Kill
Confirmed I wonder how many of those are
people who just like still have an
original 360 are they on the same
services yeah
these people really it's the same
service oh wow cool ooh
terminal it's got three votes already so
you're looking at questions here oh yeah
let's see there's someone a while ago is
saying something
no the art builder says GameSpot was my
go-to as a kid not sure what happened
used to rate my favorite games with Sly
Cooper and enslave ops you to the west
where'd you guys go I we're still here
yeah still reviewing game reviewing
games the people have changed hands a
while ago I mean back when they were
reviewing things like sigh Cooper I was
also watching GameSpot as a kid yeah
seriously but yeah I mean we're still
here we're still doing reviews we don't
do reviews no we do videos gamespot.com
though exactly and get all that cool
stuff terminal okay good they voted on
it any other three trial slash demos
that I missed that you missed there
sounds like a lot I'm trying I mean I
missed most of it was Kingdom Hearts 3
like it wasn't done
it was playable you could go play it
yeah I didn't get to but what are your
thoughts on all that do you play kiddo
Martin I played Kingdom Hearts I haven't
mixed relationship with Kingdom Hearts I
I find the scene just like I try and get
into it but then it's just way too
convoluted if you like actually invest
in absolutely but I like all the Disney
stuff I think it's literally charming
and cool I love this map me to some
wasn't to right session
oh this is try again dang hope we get
the same map yeah how much I like down
to right I think it was a I think so cuz
yeah cuz I was like I primarily remember
playing in most name - ooh sometimes a
big Jones wants to know when everyone
will be back from vacation I'll I'll
give up this week here and there
they'll be filtering back in huh yeah
most people are gonna be back next week
Tay is gonna be bout for two weeks and
then once he's out I'm actually going
away for two weeks where we going I'm
going on Japan
whoa have you been nope first time very
excited that's so cool I haven't been
either but I hope you have such a good
time I've only heard the best things
about Japan yeah we just had that
earthquake they had the day in Osaka
yeah thoughts and prayers to those
people seems like it wasn't as bad as it
could have been or anything I know
they've had some pretty rough ones there
yeah it's definitely been worse but
unfortunately it's still happening out
there hey what are you gonna do in Japan
somewhere I can do in Japan Japan you
have a list it's your first time you
gotta either wing it or just have this
big old plan yeah I'm gonna Tokyo I have
like some I asked people run in the
office like everyone in the office here
is like been to Japan at some point yeah
I feel like I'm one of the only people
who hasn't exactly so I said I think I'm
gonna do like a couple shops and like
Peter was telling me like Oh check out
this gaming shop or go to this arcade
otherwise I'm kind of just taking it
easy cool
it's just been a while all the food eat
all the food you spend a while since
I've had a vacation so I'm just kind of
looking at take it easy and enjoy my
it's gonna be really nice after this
whole all III you know you finally get
your break ben says he's just working
from home he doesn't take time off Ben
take time off bandy been the ban what
Ben relax chill Ben I mean this is
pretty chill but don't do any work okay
thanks ooh here we go up there rats you
excited for your black ops work I am
like I said the hype sort of was a slow
build for me mm-hmm
but uh I am excited oh I am excited
overall for it I kind of fell off at
black ops 3 like I played some of the
campaign's some of the multiplayer black
ops 2 I think might have been better but
that's just me with all the the extra
jumping and all that stuff more of a as
they say boots on the ground Call of
Duty player so I really got back into a
world war 2 and I'm excited from what
I've seen for black ops war I am gonna
get back into it for sure
no campaign though what do you think
about that bag where it's you know I
always like to plan the campaigns
they're the main reason I played Call of
Duty for the longest time yeah but at
the same time and I'm not they're not in
there anymore same I feel I feel like I
wouldn't haven't played the last few
campaigns anyway I played them and
they're okay but none of the campaigns
have grabbed me Oh in the way that like
I look for so for them to say like ow
we're not doing it this year it's like
it's okay with me it's so yeah doesn't
bother me that much I definitely
understand people who are like oh
there's no reason for me to play this
anymore because that was maybe the main
reason sure but also I mean there's also
a lot of people who only played
multiplayer never played the campaign
yeah that's a lot of us I assume
Activision had the data to you know say
well not that many people actually play
the campaign yeah with doing which is
the numbers are there but I'm sure the
numbers are there but yeah we'll see if
they if they can hold off with with a
really good multiplayer experience and
you know it's fine run
by me they can put their focus into that
right right like my hope would be that
it would be because the multiplayer will
be that much more like if it was just
the same level of multiplayer mmm and no
campaign then it would feel weird
especially if it they're still charging
60 bucks that's what I was gonna bring
out a price right it's like I think
that's the thing is that even if you
don't play the campaign it just adds to
that feeling of like oh I'm spending 60
bucks and I'm getting multiplayer I'm
getting zombies I'm getting a campaign
right yeah the full experience believe
so even if you don't play it you still
feel like well you know I
the price was still fair so for to still
be 60 bucks it needs to be like the
multiplayer needs to be just that much
more yeah better than ever I mean yeah
they're gonna take away the biggest part
of it we'll see though I mean they're
adding a you know black out there battle
royale black out they do have some sort
of single-player missions yeah it's like
as if the multiplayer parts are all
connected into this I figured what they
call it like a narrative yeah and you're
like playing is the one of the class
characters so I think that's where
they're gonna get some of their like
scripted sequence type stuff we'll see
no it's not I knew it
Ben's talking about how excited he is
from Mario Tennis yeah that's on Friday
over right are you guys gonna stream I
think so I think Ben's gonna stream it's
I might not be here Friday okay my boy
Ben djenka will be here though he will
be here and he will stream I've made
that executive decision stream on Friday
I feel like with every Nintendo console
there's a tennis game Mario Tennis even
in the boat
Virtual Boy Oh Fred for smash I'm very
excited for Ashes there's a moment we
just buy like pure luck I happen to be
on the same flight going home as a bunch
of people from the office uh-huh it's
like Ben - Justin Joey Rob we all had
her switch in sofa Ben Ben freakin
didn't bring a switch oh well we're all
like let's all play Mario Kart
so we just played Mario Kart for like
the hour flight nice just perfect right
and it felt so good and I was just
thinking like dude once
mash comes out and we're all playing
smash on a flight together it'll be like
you play Mario Kart only you'll be
screaming at each other like so that'll
be so so cool it's like a Nintendo
commercial yeah right it's like you look
at those commercials and you're like
yeah okay like oh I'm sure that but then
you do and you're like no this is
actually really fun yeah this is what it
was meant for it was designed for stuff
like this yeah smash on a plane give us
our flight jealous that's the only time
I ever have less I can yeah just join it
just going to LA any other like when I
have to go home oh it's like a nine-hour
flight oh wow it one way if I get one
way to sign ours otherwise it's like six
and then I have to wait like a couple
hours and then another three because
connecting flight acting yeah where's
home for you
Vermont Vermont okay so all the way
across the country so it's a long flight
ooh rough game for me but our team won
I always find the killcam never looks as
cool no yeah it's like check it out it's
all badass that one was pretty cool cuz
he got a double but uh yeah most of the
time it's like these older games they
it's always the final killcam in World
War two it was like the best kill camera
whoever got the most kills and the
shortest amount of time they took they
took that from overwatch very very
rightly so yeah it was a good idea who
we unlock the Dragunov
not much of a sniper though are you no
no never been good with snipers I
started getting a little better at them
I like it in games like Battlefield
where I can kind of like just find it
like a spot and perch you feel more like
a like a sniper a game like this I'd
rather just stick with like a shorter
like assault rifle yeah machine gun and
kind of go that way sniping can mean
more in battlefield two you know a lot
of players cuz he you kind of post up
and actually feel like a sniper here you
can get quick stoke quick scope and it's
like you know that's just how it is
many people have mastered the quick
scope yeah let's just never been and
there's much smaller Maps much more or
much smaller there there was a couple
into that I remember we're really nice
and big there's like a tree
noble-looking one oh yeah yeah I
remember that one I forget what it's
called big field though big field and
then in the middle I had like those
tunnels yeah yep forget the name of it I
heard that one being a good sniper one
let's see here and before we hop into
this match I think it's ya know m4 it is
Ben no snakes on a plane
brought to you by GameSpot in Olive
Garden I can get Olive Garden I will
happily stream any game if all of garden
will sponsor me now this map was remade
back into World War two oh really yeah
like like old Paris yeah oh that's cool
ooh so doesn't make me better play this
one the DLC maps I assume yeah was one
of the latest ones actually it was the
second one the resistance yeah that's
actually really awesome I like that
there we go
so the layout is fresh in my mind yeah I
just hanging out I know they've been
like adding I think they added a bunch
of older maps to black ops 3 or
something yeah keep updating black ops 3
and yeah it is weird but yeah if you
pre-ordered black ops for you can get a
you can get the four classic maps on
your black ops 3 account and then
they'll be available in black ops for
all really interesting yeah they like
added all those old zombie maps to 3
that's right like earlier this year or
late last year
yeah the Chronicles Maps actually just
made it backward not backwards
compatible its PlayStation Plus this
month oh that's right
Oh black ops 3 is fine already its fury
yes plus member and I actually don't
mind black ops 3 multiplayer I I know
people are whatever about the mobility
stuff and it's not my favorite I
certainly prefer like titanfall I think
just oh yeah but it's definitely
playable it's still fun it's still fun
it's just didn't a stick as hard as two
did for me two or one especially yeah
absolutely
hey you've got your history of black ops
coming soon don't you I do they should
hopefully be coming a little bit cool oh
great
probably probably after
my vacation cool and I'll get that going
yeah gonna be doing that got a couple of
history OHS we're working on I think
we're gonna we're gonna try and do a
battlefield one with Rob oh cool
that should be fun that's the thing
about e3 you come back and there's all
these games and outs and you're like ah
it's time to turn a brush off the
history offer for double make yeah and
yeah ooh nice my own a support streak I
think I am oh hi I'm lit that's this
guy's name okay let's see here thanks
for this whole campaign if you're
referring to black ops yes I believe
black ops says everything you're
preferring to this as well yes wow I
cannot pick up that package oh look at
that oh that's why is this back when
they used to have yeah we're like host
migration yeah you would it would just
pause the game to switch hosts over yeah
yeah but it's better than like booting
out of a game entirely I think Cod for
and your modern warfare 2 didn't even
have that at that point Thanks Oh barely
got that one oh I know I couldn't pick
it up it was a decoy I don't work I was
just like huddling around my care
package which was a decoy if someone
does try to pick it up from the other
team they'll explode it's great that's
what happens that makes more sense
forgot they had those there were so many
streaks in this game oh my gosh okay I
was behind the wall that's a good gun
though yeah well wait you saw that right
yeah hmm madness hmm yeah when I played
uh when I played black ops 2 there were
a lot of cheaters oh yeah I got in a
couple matches where it was just like it
just cuts to this like the cam of like
that this guy kills me and then it comes
to like the person who killed you came
is just a dude standing there with a
sniper rifle ten people are standing
around him just constantly shooting him
and he's defending they're firing a
sniper rifle and I was like that's what
happened to me too legit there's a lot
of people hacking the
their games so badly like god mode
aimbots I've seen it at all like oh yeah
oh great wow we're getting nuked that's
how badly we're doing whoa well quickly
for you viewers you can see what a leak
what it's like to get mo webbed in this
game I don't I don't remember if the
match ends or if we all just die but
here it goes like fallout shelter
challenge complete get killed by Moab
they reward you for dying in this game
okay the match is not over
that's good oh I thought I always ended
the match just thought I think and one
of the games that did I thought maybe it
was cute it ended the match someone was
up here now there's all this fallout in
there I think my hood is gone
nope wait yeah do I have a rope yeah so
little more it's just more of a like a
filter though I would love to see you
really bring that back in a call duty I
want it to like properly like destroy
the map and change it completely and it
becomes a good different map almost your
rival to it one of ours
No Oh crud 3d ranks thanks okay yikes
fencing you mess around with BlazBlue
yeah we're gonna we're gonna stream
blazblue tomorrow morning
sweet 11:00 a.m. 11:00 a.m. we're gonna
stream some blazblue they just added
seven new characters whoa yeah
three of them are six of them DLC packs
and then ones free yang from Ruby she's
pretty cool I've heard you talk good
things about that game it's it like it's
crazy that game yeah we guys played in
the speed zone yeah we really liked it
well Michael be there no Michael and I
fortunately who off for the week so
it'll be me and been streaming okay
minoan and the other one I'm streaming
is I think in the afternoon we're gonna
stream quake because that is currently
oh wow free to play it was free to play
last week it was they announced that as
part of their press conference that's
huge
they extended it for another week okay
and it's it's actually great because
that game is I like that game a lot but
when I was playing a lot of it there
weren't any there were is a pretty small
amount of players and it was always just
two people who are
really good at quick right so it was
like man like I know I'm not that great
at quake but also I'm just getting my
like me right now like I thought it was
a little better than like really badly
so when the free-to-play week opened up
there were suddenly oh man
okay I got him stopped to look at you
and like unloaded my clip that was great
yeah but they've added like way more
people have shown up so now it feels
just a little bit more balanced in terms
of like skill levels something okay cool
I'm like I'm playing with a lot of
people who are new or who are more at my
skill level so I feel like I'm actually
playing him better yeah and I have like
a better chance so I'm having I'm having
way more fun with the game now that more
people are playing it which is great
then says quake and quite good times
like it's good time so yeah I'll be
streaming that tomorrow as well at - yes
and then here goes I know we got
fortnight's base I gotta find somebody
to stream that because the two people
who usually steer in fortnight are both
on vacation okay okay you're both Nick's
on vacation and so is Erik probably been
I think that's the only person here
plays fortnight ready really enough yeah
busy day for Ben tomorrow easy day for
Ben yeah
oh and then Friday we got Mario yes
finally I did something good and didn't
die ah I knew it
Oh awful no it's okay time
gube says our AP chem Debbie dab
sanitize our Nick get a little dab dab
somebody says no PC version if you're
referring to wait I see this is this
well it's because this is backwards
compatible that's why we're playing it
yeah is it in the Xbox store and buy yes
it is I don't I can tell you how much it
is give me a sec where's just McDonald's
just McDonnell is back over in the u.k
and not UK you apologies Jess and the a
you just got home they're all flying
back now yeah I assume
if you're not seeing much content from
anyone it's because everyone's just so
busy and tired taking breaks let's see
here and all these call signs remember
all these well we don't have many unlock
but so many books yeah if you want to
get the game on on Xbox 15 bucks cool
Digital toxic look at all these whoo
that was fun collecting those there were
some that you can only get like after
some crazy challenges right I remember I
was proud of this little Captain Price
when I had oh wow well village here we
go everyone's voting here
nice I wish Sega had this oh um me too I
guess but uh sure Sega's been out of the
game for so long now miss them in the
console market I wish I could like Call
of Duty all my dreams yes the failure
says best Cod all right modern warfare 3
yeah it's a good ooh you don't see that
opinion that often but there are
definitely people who like black ops to
read quite a bit or not black I'm sorry
um montemagno warfare 3 I think every
Call of Duty has his fans I even found
somebody online who said they thought
ghost was the best one which interesting
agree to disagree but amen you do you
yeah exactly I that's actually where I
started to fall off with Call of Duty
was ghosts yeah this was like the last
one I played and then I was like you
know I think I'm kind of down with it
for now I was sure I didn't come back
for a while I didn't actually go back
until infinite warfare
so it actually been a really long time
that's where I was still continuing my
break I bought ghosts played it a little
and then stopped dropped
advanced warfare infinite warfare and
then got back with a little bit with
black ops 3 yeah yeah I like I kind of
went after so after infinite warfare I
went back to black ops though try is
what I did were you here when advanced
warfare or infinite warfare launched
like did you have to actually make
videos about any stuff I did you did I
had to make I had laughing I had to make
a multiplayer tips video for infinite
warfare and I liked that game's campaign
I did not like the multiplayer at all
whoo and I remember just like having to
make that that's a video I'm just being
like this is not something I want to I
want to be spending my time on and like
I'm sitting there like trying to play it
and just like not doing well and not
enjoy myself in like Rob's right next to
me playing like titanfall oh man way to
rub it in Rob
and said that's kind of like the you
think that's like what they were going
for like the whole time folding actually
I forget oh I think they were definitely
they definitely they came out around the
same time yeah I mean they they went the
year after so I think for sure they were
trying to do titanfall movement it just
didn't have the same feel like titanfall
truism you can go so fast and you're
just like the speed of it everything
about it feels great yeah
and it just felt so stiff in infinite
warfare I'm really not digging it I've
heard the progression system also being
like just kind of like I don't know I
feel like I didn't even like I just
stand up fully I can't even really
manage yeah I didn't pop that game in my
ex but I like the single-player I
actually like that game single-player
campaign I thought it was pretty good
you Inc nope got me Obama cares bro I
love that that is that is the name of an
xbox profile that was made when this
game came out yeah its period correct
for this is it's definitely period
appropriate for sure I love it okay they
are all over there
all these call-outs it's just that's the
thing you take away like what's that
sorry oh just those call-outs like you
hear the sounds of the weapons all the
call-outs everything those are the kind
of audio cues that bring you back oh
right yeah I'm like won this game out
2010 or something like that
2011 brings me right back there though I
was replaying uh uh I've been playing
Assassin's Creed origins then in play it
last year okay I kind of seemed on
Odyssey kind of made me want to go back
and play and I'm actually really like in
the game I'm playing either it felt like
they got stacked on each other like I
felt like I came out at a bad time with
Wyatt in play it came up the same day as
Mario Odyssey okay and it came out this
thing to his Wolfenstein so no you got
left in the dust for me it's a good game
though but it has a very different feel
from like older
assassin's creed's but they have a
couple the same like sound effects ah
like some of the Animus sound effects is
some of the certain like musical jingles
are like still from like the original
Assassin's Creed I hear them I'm like oh
wow yeah the original game like and
that's that's kind of cool that's
special that's cool gosh Hong is
Assassin's Creed I think of like the
early ps3 days yeah when I think of like
the you know 2007 what were you doing in
2007 she was I doing in 2007 I would've
been in high school I just finished
myself whoo there we go yeah that'd have
been yeah that I've been like pink
sophomore year I think I think good
times up no good times
I just got killed oops man did you ever
get a nuke in any one of these games no
I've been nuked enough but I never yeah
but I never I'm just not that good same
I'm more of a rusher like I I always
like my KDS always that like I saw it
would like one cuz I cuz you just trade
off evenly yeah for better or worse like
that's just how I play I'm kind of the
same I was rushing ah great rushed right
into that one the game that I had
probably gotten like above average at
was Halo cuz I just played hello-o me
that was the game that I considered
myself like you know I'm I'm decently
good at this yeah playing uh getting my
Xbox 360 like back in the day I got it
for Halo and then an airplane called
duty for cuz they uh it was one after
the other and all my friends started
merging to Cod for like let's check this
out mm-hmm and sure enough that's where
it all started for me
I got my 360 so late because I thought
to myself like I know I'm gonna get
addicted to this kind of stuff I held
off on a 360 for nice for years
yeah 360 was actually my first home
console
I had a PC for longest time and I played
a lot of console games like my friends
houses yeah be like okay you go to that
friend's house if you want to play ps2
yeah now what just changed man doing
that like you know Super Nintendo back
in the day
totally Oh Michael's got a Super
Nintendo let's go over to his place
right I've got the Genesis so so yeah I
had a pc for the longest time and then
finally with the 360 that was the one
where I was like I want to get my own
console yeah oh that was cheap that was
awful I'm sorry to that guy just that
was such a stretch of a stab it is nice
though to have okay great
you know in World War 2 the game to have
stabs that don't that aren't one hit oh
really
yeah you do 80% damage so you gotta like
shoot them a few more times and it
stinks oh we lost by five points dang
that guns that little overpowered
sidearm you can use those number at
Kimbo just oh yeah ridiculously short
range but those were ripped or anything
that's pretty good look at that one guy
though 37 kills man I would say he's
cheating but like honestly like he might
just be that good like that yeah that
happens remember that happened to me
when I was trying to record the other
day for black ops like I was up there it
was great because I think a lot of
people jumping there are some people
jumping back in but there are a lot of
people just like playing these games for
the first time I can tell ya one of the
weirdest experiences I had was I when I
was playing I had to do the history of
Uncharted mm-hmm and I was like I'm
gonna try and play some uncharted 2
multiplayer oh man the servers are still
alive they're still alive Wow there was
still people playing deathmatch you
couldn't get into like death and team
death match any of the vs. modes I
couldn't really find
anyone yeah I know people are playing
but there were enough to get like a full
match going it was pretty small and I
got in there and they're all like top
ranked oh man man it's the people that
never wanted to leave
exactly but then I popped in my first
match I came out like first place with
like 20-something kills and I was like
nice wait I got it was like really
satisfying because I used to play a lot
of uncharted multiplayer you know I
didn't get into it that's another series
I got into late so I bought I bought
like a compilation pack I think for the
PS yeah the ps4 and but those didn't
have the multi play exactly which is a
shame yeah I mean I think of all the
other what's the other naughty dog game
The Last of Us had multiplayer too like
was it similarly good a little different
a much slower paced but I also loved
that multiplayer as well yeah that's
really good I tried to was a much faster
pace like it was kind of going for like
a Gears feel but right with more
mobility and yeah I played a lot of - I
played a lot of threes multiplayer I
played nice on both of those and then
I've only played a bit of four I played
a like a couple weekends before but I
didn't get into it the way I think I was
yeah at that point it's pretty good
though I was just like I heard or you
kind of I feel a bit I just tried it out
I barely played a multiplayer even
though like after any naughty dog game
I'm thinking of Last of Us and uncharted
like I wanted so much more like I
downloaded all the DLC I like it was
like a story a book you didn't want to
end yeah I can either replay this all
the way but I just want more like I'm so
sad this is over
totally but at the same time like multi
players might not necessarily be that
fixed anyway exactly that's it wasn't
for me I tried to buy that a Uncharted
game on the PS Vita and all the gold in
the best yeah and I started it but I
didn't finish it it's okay yeah last was
multiplayer is really really good I like
that multiplayer quite a bit I wonder if
anyone still playing it cuz you got the
ps4 version yeah but I they did announce
that there is gonna be multiplayer for
two which is great oh this is good I
like that multiplayer and that multiply
had a pretty big following
so I would grated the parents continuing
that lots of us to you're excited oh
yeah you have to be yeah definitely I'm
thinking work here here we go they're
crowding around ooh
friends so gonna be a while though yeah
didn't even give a release day I think I
don't think they did either now the
gameplay look good though did I imagine
we won't at the very least fall of next
year yeah at the very least anyone know
what the current player count is well we
were saying that there was about
eighteen thousand fifteen so you were
good to get in a match if you want to do
that am I getting like double xp kills I
feel like every kill I'm getting is
worth 200 points I did put in a code
from a back of doritoes I got no way
really valid find an old roomie not have
been pretty good
you should just said yeah and I would
have fell for it this map it's a lot of
you are saying where's my work for to
nobody wants this show we hear you yeah
I mean I've played to if they had it the
reason they haven't made it backwards
compatible yet is probably because
they're gonna do well hmm I was gonna
say it's because they're gonna do a
remaster of mom were afraid to but then
they already confirmed that it's just
gonna be the single player yeah did they
actually confirm Ella man it was so back
and forth for a while he did I couldn't
you're wrong but I want to say they
confirm there's not gonna be multiplayer
bummer oh man that guy was just waiting
for me dad hits killed me I have such
mixed feelings on that remaster of the
original Modern Warfare welcome well so
it's a very good remaster I think the
campaign's excellent and it multiple
layer feels very good it's the fact that
they will one they weren't originally
selling it you had to get that special
edition that's right I waited I knew
there'd be a solo release I forget how
long it took a really long time for to
finally come out but I didn't want
infinite warfare I waited other thing
about it and this is the worst thing is
is that the one they added loop boxes
into the multiplayer
that was terrible they also didn't
include the DLC maps no just so I think
it was ten maps yes which was it's like
whenever anyone buys a remaster it
should all be there yes just like the
way it works right like you're getting
the whole experience they're getting
everything
yeah and for them to still withhold old
multiplayer like maps is crazy and not
only that I believe they costed more to
buy than they did that like oh I
probably bought it like it sounds like
10 bucks when the game first came out it
was like 15 I don't call me on this but
like if that was just like what like
you're trying to sucker you out of your
money and that is I was rude I feel good
I don't feel good at all oh we are
playing on the Xbox one yes we are
playing on the Xbox one so it's a
shotgun only next round okay I mean if
it's all right I'll do it for you Vince
legacy all right let's say you first
gotta create one of these create a quick
class yeah oh man look at ones already
here the automatic usas-12 I don't know
let's see let me see what the other
options are I think the spaz was my
favorite and it's unlocked do it
excellent sweet at class five let's see
if I should change my perks I will need
sleight of hand
check quick-draw mm-hmm
sure I'll keep that instance the
original modern warfare
backwards-compatible oh I don't know
it's good question I don't see why they
need to because they want to charge
people money for right to buy it so yes
Activision I would totally see not doing
it especially the fact that they charge
people for the multiplayer maps other
companies have actually done it like for
example Ubisoft of all reasons made the
last gen version of Black Flag
backwards-compatible interesting which
is weird because it's like you could
just get a current version that'll look
better yeah but you can they're like hey
if you want it for really one you want
to spend the money that's really nice
plus one you saw
that's like an interesting like yeah why
not just do it um Oh
striker class I don't have the striker
unlocked actually it's one of the it's
one of the classes that just comes built
into the game I should use the striker
maybe yes
the original modern warfare is backwards
compatible actually good to know
they made it backwards compatible back
in March so after they did it after they
did after the remaster so I bet you
what'll happen is they'll do this
remaster yeah and then you know like a
six months or something like that
they'll they'll put out the they also
I'm thinking just now because I played a
lot of the modern warfare remastered
version as soon as I got it and they
added guns like guns that weren't
originally in the game yep I think they
were doing that for the loot boxes I
imagine why yeah like you could I don't
know if he can get him through the loop
box I don't remember I did I think I
might have bought one cuz I I really
liked the LMGs in that game so I bought
like they added anyone and I had to do
it again they're like looking at me like
moneybags they're like sucker through it
in the game for people like me who are
like I gotta get it yep that's me though
what's it that's all right now hope
someone's over here nope taken care of
ah baloney I i like shotguns but it's
always weird to me how i don't know like
like as far as like a viability of like
i like it it's like a secondary weapon
but to make it my primary weird yeah
there goes your KD really i mean oh
let's see you or small maps only liam
weirdly enough I had like an amazing
kill streak and battlefield 3 recently
replaying that one at work and we were
playing on a map where what I would do
is I would have my buddy like support me
with a sniper from the roof and I would
essentially like flank and he's kind of
shooting at him and then I would flank
around a wall and then I would run into
the building with the shotgun
and I'm just askin them all and it
actually worked in
credibly well I feel like battlefield
works like that a lot more than any Cod
right
everyone's like every man for himself in
cotton but uh it's good to hear that
people are still playing nice on
battlefields like duck games at the
carnival yeah seriously oh wow oh great
what a mess that was Oh someone says you
SAS is the best shotgun they're all
pretty good in this game
I forget like I'm just trying to think
of like any Opie ones any automatic one
might be super you say what console
we're playing the Xbox one yeah it's
backwards compatible today couple people
uh black over says you can only find
parties in team deathmatch online I pass
yes that was my experience with black
ops as well what's your doing everyone's
just playing deathmatch and team
deathmatch Oh which we actually always
might go to modes single duty anyway I
never really liked objective notes in
Call of Duty personally I know a lot of
people really enjoyed absolutely I
started getting into domination
domination with world war two like more
than ever it's uh they're longer games
you can get more kills and you can I
mean you play the objective get all
those points it's easier to get streaks
- oh friendly I think that's ultimately
why I preferred death matches because it
feels like the game is designed around
just getting kills everyone would just
get kills anyway and barely focus on the
objectives yeah mode where at least it
doesn't matter I don't have to like get
frustrated that no one's like helping me
out on the on the point or anything like
yeah so there's there's always gonna be
someone who doesn't play the objective
boom oh wow that was hell's stretch he
must have already been wounded okay I
don't know how I didn't die there right
here
nope little little dots on the mini-map
as soon as you kill someone they don't
fade away automatically I'm still like
lingering around oh I'm excited that
they're changing that
Oh which part the the mini-map oh yeah
it's gonna be like a more of a fog and
you can't immediately see everyone yeah
because instinctively I do feel like you
just spend so much time like eyeing the
map I do yeah
everyone does well everyone does but
it's like oh man like I don't know like
you I feel like you should be wanting to
look like what's in front of the one
stabbed using a rod smart change yeah
well see how it works on me maybe we'll
just shift the focus back onto the
what's in front of you instead of
looking up all somebody says play black
ops one hey I already made it backwards
that's fun if you jump into any black
ops game right now I had a great time
the other week when we were capturing
yeah that was fun this is fun - this
these maps are all like so memorable for
me
I do miss already Wow
in World War 2 unlimited sprint I'm
worried I've gotten so accustomed to
that and here you know you stop every
few seconds all right you know I'm
actually surprised they're not doing the
black ops remaster instead hmm on
warfare 2 but that made more sense to me
that would be cool I think that it's
it's a Treyarch decision though I mean I
imagine so yeah cuz that would be kind
of interesting of like instead of being
like hey because then it's like hey we
don't have campaign this year but that'd
be a good alternative like if you get a
remastered version of black ops yeah
your campaign fix yeah that'd be kind of
cool yeah that badly at least make more
sense to me I didn't do too bad with the
shotgun there's I don't think they have
a thing with with modern were like do we
know in the modern warfare remaster or
to remaster is coming out I don't know
because I don't think they're like I
don't think they're doing a like a
package deal the way they were with
infinite warfare we check I don't think
so either
two masked LMG next round okay
Oh Vince Vince the legacy again let's
see if we can dig one up here
switch out the UMP he's just you just
recommending new stuff yeah well we'll
be able to do at least one more match
maybe two yep can't go wrong with a see
here forget which one is the fastest
let's see here fire rate does look like
the LM 86 let's go with that
so they actually still haven't even
confirmed that it's happening yet mm-hmm
all these little green news thing all
these little they get me I always want
to clear them out but there's not gonna
be enough time
mm-hmm I assume they had confirmed it
but they apparently have not no huh no
but it still says it won't have
multiplayer ooh this will be good John
the terminal so this the last thing we
have this is on our website
the latest second markjames it says that
reportedly it's gonna be only like 25
bucks it would just have the single
player wouldn't have the multiplayer and
it was supposed to come out in April
oh it was okay see I knew there so now
it makes me wonder if it even is
happening right now yeah but the way
they're holding out or something yeah or
maybe the everyone's like maybe they
decided to add back in multiplayer then
they listened so my guess would be that
they would do the whole like it'll come
with with black ops then right and the
best er thing like here's their campaign
yeah again now they still haven't said
anything about it yet no oh let's stop
talking about it that makes me wonder if
it'll even happen this year because I
feel like they would have already said
something about it if it was yeah maybe
I mean I wonder what they like learn
from putting out mana warfare remastered
yeah because a lot of people I know play
it for so little amount of time I
believe for like you know two months
tops and I really enjoyed it but I don't
know if it's got legs anymore I wonder
if they learned that and don't plan to
either plan to scrap modern warfare 2
entirely or well that may explain why
they delay a test on the multiplayer if
it was like oh and not enough people
actually played it that much yeah like
we're not gonna hold our servers open
for you guys
I don't know what they're thinking is
Vince wants to know how do we download
modern warfare 3 and go pick it up on
the Xbox one store yes it is a very keen
bucks also if you have a disc
yeah just put the disc into your xbox
and it'll work that list is increasing
that's so cool with all this backwards
yeah I love that about the Xbox yeah
it's it's probably in my opinion the
best thing the Xbox has done this
generation yeah it's a really strong a
feature right now it's something that I
wish wish the PlayStation did anything
like oh me too
the closest they have is the PlayStation
now stuff but that's like a streaming
service and I tried it
there's just games you can't there's
very little games you can make it work
with I feel especially not a multiplayer
game no way yeah absolutely not and have
like decent internet at home and I gave
it a shot and it was still just so like
baggy yeah I felt the other day I was
trying to download some old stuff just
to see what they had on the ps4 in it
right I think they like wiped everything
so so that you can play PSN now or what
is it the PS now PS now yeah they're
really pushing that and I don't want it
now I don't either
I'd much rather they do a a like
backwards-compatible thing like Xbox
yeah great
which is probably too late to do this
time but yeah PS 5 we're looking at you
they wanted it I'm great they should do
it they should lean into it
I really think they should Hooper here
goddamn uh no like what do you think of
e3 I liked it
you think it was really good it was good
this year
and I know there are some people who I
think we're maybe expecting more like
crazy big announcements sure I was there
was a lot beforehand like there was a
lot beforehand yeah sure a lot of pre e3
stuff first yeah a lot of leaks and then
just then just kind of maybe getting
Hetal leaks and just announcing stuff
yeah but smash Kingdom Hearts showing
like everything I saw I was really
really excited about there we go wow I
forgot about these things I just leave
it there someone's gonna destroy it I
knew it
yeah jerk now I'm shooting my own Sam
turret great Oh hit more thanks bro he
killed me of course this is going for
$8.00 at my local gamestop I look just
for a second oh great I looked away for
a sec yeah so that's the thing like you
can get it for 15 bucks if you manage to
find yourself a like a used copy it's
great well yeah fact I learned with
backwards-compatible stuff because it
doesn't actually use your disk it just
reads that you have the disk and then
downloads the game it rips it right yeah
like an emulator so it doesn't matter
what region you have I have interests
all version of black ops 2 that's right
what did member we didn't work otherwise
and I put it in and it's just like yeah
yeah blocking yeah that's great so if
you can get yourself like a PAL version
that's like cheaper or something you can
totally do that and that'll work and
then they started making these weird
like hybrid editions that like for black
ops black ops 1 it has the like Xbox one
case that's right it was so weird then
the case is a little different because
it says like xbox 360 and Xbox one on it
it's a special version of the the one
case they made for backwards compatible
games I thought you had like this weird
bootleg but it's they're making them
that's and it's like really interesting
like they're reprinting them with like
yeah like the box are and everything
it's so interesting
yes Ben it is available for 15 bucks oh
yeah yeah someone's thing if your disc
to scratch it works yeah as long as it
just can read it and it enough to know
what the game is it'll work because it's
not actually like spinning you're
discouraged
it's just using it it's just using it as
a like a ID basically to like ensure
that you have it you own it is this Matt
from Modern Warfare - yes it is terminal
that's right oh boy I am low I unlocked
joint ops and p9 I remember that little
gun I didn't do too bad with that l86
yeah alright why don't we do one more
and then we'll call here cool I'm going
for an hour interchange oh I remember
that one that's a fun one it's a big one
let's just Oh doesn't look like I'm
gonna get the votes though now we'll see
what I should use here the scar I'm
gonna do it no wait I have one already
I have a class already for that
somewhere yeah Dark Lord says this map
looks identical to modern warfare - I
think it is just a map for my warfare -
painkiller 15 says no Russian that was a
big one oh yeah and remember you boot up
the game it's like there's some stuff
here in this game like you can either
say yes or no - its broad yeah black ops
is the same thing it did which one the
first one oh I forget yeah I think it's
just like base like that torture scene
where you're like oh yeah
punch him it's pretty gnarly I think
like that'll turn off or when Ice Cube
gets killed Bowman spoiler maybe that's
the best part about black ops is that in
the multiplayer you can make Ice Cube be
the announcer yeah that's right if
you're on the US team like he does all
the announcements and it'll be like Kill
Confirmed our UAV is online it's like
the hardest announcements ever it's so
good I was like yes oh I remember this
Madison's great yeah let's see hmm
where's his infinite warfare is
underrated I'd agree I definitely the
campaign for sure multiplayer I didn't
really care for it personally but I I
agree that that game got too much got
dumped on to Mars when can I get the
Snoop Dogg voice back for free was there
I know boobs messed with me but I
actually said where there is look Dawg
or like a like an iced tea voice pack oh
my god all the rappers I see I'm gonna
let this out call
of duty amount sir I don't know man I
remember yes in ghosts
oh and ghosts ghosts 1308 ACK you could
get four ghosts my ghosts or the dog for
three bucks that's so funny
like we download what was it weighs that
has those GPS with celebrities like they
do the voice up right that'd be cool
they should do that more often I don't
think they did that much anymore after
ghost um you think you don't have the
game I can think of they actually like
lean into that for a while I haven't
done in a while I don't think is dota 2
dota 2 but they had like you can have
GLaDOS from Portal oh wow
do your announcer or get the the guy
from Baskin your play that a supergiant
game it's really he's got like the gruff
voice he's like okay it's like the kid
went did this and you could get that as
an answer which is really great and then
um it was actually during season one
before it got like as big as it is today
but Rick and Morty oh right Rick and
Morty announced their pack for that's
cool so boy towers being taken in the
middle holy crap he's like calm down
Morty hey we had him at they're just
enrolling yeah we had a three stage was
great talking about his new uh VR game
oh no Bob Jensen Starcraft 2 likes
announcers oh did they have any cool
ones for StarCraft I like I like the
idea of games that do that there's a
they never came to fruition
unfortunately but there was a while when
epic was working on a new Unreal
Tournament it technically still exists
let me have an updated I remember
they're two years yeah it's real bummer
but one of the big things for it was
that what you could they were kind of
pitching it as as like open-ended where
it's like hey anything you make you can
make anything you want for this game
like skin using like weapon skins map it
was so custom elaborate and and you
could potentially sell them like it was
meant to be this like modular like thing
where you could they work on taking the
idea of like mods but making it like you
can actually get paid to like you know
yeah like a commune
system and it was a great idea
unfortunately I just don't think there
was enough there for and you know no one
really did much with it but one of the
things they were pitching was like like
an announcer pack like you could do like
an announcer pack for it and I was like
man the idea of like anyone could just
make their own announcer pack
that's pretty ahead of a super but super
cool I still think that's a great idea
but it kind of fell off I remember we
stopped hearing about that yeah they
haven't announced it in like a year and
a half kinda now that fortnight's as
because it is something tells me in the
water in the water huh so I lived
thankfully like quake champions exist so
there is ways that marina fix thankfully
yeah no I the idea of just like anyone
can make an announcer pack because then
you can have celebrities to just do that
right yeah like they don't have to like
sign anything make a huge deal they
could just do it themselves for ya for
the love of the game like that and make
money off of it themselves
yeah well so like I don't know how
that's great I love that idea
whoo the ACR someone's behind me watch
they have a lot of celebrities though on
on the Call of Duty games always have a
they've been running with celebrities
for years it's somebody I guess they're
not gonna have any in black ops war mmm
I didn't see any unless in the zombies
maps but they all seemed I think those
were all original characters yeah
they've been the the standing staples
for the zombie series for a while yeah
so I think um you know I'm sure they can
sneak it in maybe somewhere but I as far
as I'm concerned I think black ops for
might be the first call duty in a long
time to not have a celebrity voice in it
and they might be in there somewhere who
will see and there's always DLC also
true and well yeah there's no story this
time bringing bring back that scream
talk voice back here we go oh that's
this that's the roof Oh awful to bed for
tonight doesn't have like an announcer
voice otherwise that's how you could get
that in there yeah I can do anything
right now yeah they could get like like
a drink boys pack yeah he's been down to
like he remember when he streamed with
ninja a few times he oh yeah he's like
I'd like to see all the dances on put on
to four night all the funds oh yeah from
like the hotline bling' oh absolutely
and all the kids would buy it well cool
all right man
that was a really fun time throwback for
sure absolutely
lol says are you playing against a bunch
of Timmy no thumbs
I don't know I sort of felt like one but
appreciate the comment yeah alright guys
thank you for joining us for some modern
warfare 3 thank you Richard for joining
us good job anytime always happy to have
you on and yeah you can go check this
out for yourself if you want to it's
over on the Xbox store for 15 bucks or
you could try and find yourself a copy
for cheaper as we mentioned earlier yep
if you still got your copy throw it in
exactly and tomorrow we're gonna be back
at 11 o'clock we're gonna be doing some
BlazBlue they just have this new
characters today and then late in the
day we're gonna play some quick
champions I'm sure yeah put in for that
and see you guys next time
Ziya
you
you
you